the jurogan experience look you get out
in that world joe
you you're famous everywhere you've
never been to these places but when you
get there they're gonna know you
or there's a thing that happened to me
years ago in london
where i was in a restaurant and i was
kind of waiting for the table and
and when the lady she asked me my name
she said well she now go david
she goes with david on the list what's
your last name chappelle
and she looks up and i look around and
everyone's kind of looking
i could tell they'd heard of me but they
didn't know
that that was oh right right that kind
of thing yeah
this was this was after i quit the show
but not long after like 0.506
what did you do for those 10 years a lot
of [ __ ] i learned a lot
i mean but it was it was a humble
existence you know i
i had had young children and i was
raising my kids
i was living a suburban life uh and then
every once in a while i get this feeling
like i'm the
funniest guy i got to get out there and
i would like fly to denver do a week in
denver or something
and that's when you would read i was
doing like these six hour shows i
performed like i was desperate for it
i loved yeah and uh
at one point i had done uh one of these
big comedy tours the live nation put
together that oddball tour
and i did all right i mean i had a good
run i wiped out in hartford and ed was
all over the internet that was the first
time that thing had happened to me
uh but for the most part the tour went
good but it was a tough tour for me
because it was a long show i had to
close it you know
my chops weren't as tight as they
normally were but i wouldn't i didn't
suck by any means but
you know could have been bumbling it was
humbling but
it made me want to go back
and and the shows were like every show
was like 20 000 seats they were like all
these
what year was this around [ __ ] i can't
remember
obama was president maybe i don't know
eight nine ten
but you were you were famous for just
showing up places you were just flying
that's the one i stats when i started i
actually
in the summer i started riding
motorcycles
which is like very uncharacteristic of
me but i loved it i would and i wrote
my ride my bike across country and i did
i cheated i had a tour bus with me
trailer so if it rained or something or
if i just wanted to bail
i could but i rode across country
and i'd never seen america like that we
talked about how big it is and and
expansive and
man i saw all the little pockets on a
bike you know you really yeah
feel the environment you see things um
and i would i'd stop and play one of my
favorite birthdays was here in austin
i was i've never been to austin raleigh
and i pulled up on 6th street i've been
to austin but i've never seen austin
pulled up on 6th street it was my
birthday i was riding with the guys
what do you want to do for your birthday
you know at that time i wasn't drinking
or smoking or anything
i said i want to do stand-up and i found
a bar
it was it was right around closing and i
saw the dj packing up and i said can i
use your microphone
and he recognized me so he's like oh
yeah yeah yeah and i went up there and i
just started talking [ __ ]
and you know but it was just like you
know teasing the bar staff as they're
cleaning up
talking to patrons and you know get it
home fast buddy and all that [ __ ] right
and people laugh and they kind of was
like doing
i used to do street comedy in new york
it kind of reminded me of that like
building a crowd
and after a while people stopped and
listened out now i'm not a tech savvy
dude
twitter had come out and i guess people
had started tweeting like yo it's just
crazy there's people just in here ran
man i took like an hour that place was
packed
and i must have stayed on stage three or
four hours wow
and you know they closed the door they
locked the door because it was after
hours
and i was in there killing it wow best
birthday ever had one of the best
birthdays i've had
sometime around when i turned 40
i just decided that i'm gonna have fun
you know like right now you know this is
a weird thing to talk about after dmx
passed
and black rob and you know now far more
often people from my peer group
pass away and it just makes me feel like
it's not a midlife crisis it's almost
the opposite of that
it's like look i know i don't get to
stay here forever
my time is limited and precious and and
i don't take any of these
things for granted i'll take this money
for granted this platform
and i'm not talking about the fame
platform i'm talking about comedy
this genre like i made
this genre it's been so
good for me catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for
free only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience